the amateur from
spain will have
a look but getting runners b5 again
comes now i think more often
than the 4 because
unfortunately i don't really have
a clue about it
i only know very roughly how to
stand up there
is also this variant
i had last time  seen
as an idea on bishop c6 and can take pawns
so since i am familiar with
other things here
it might make
bishop to 6 runs six of
course the main variant also works and
then always knows how to quickly with the long hair
and always attacks like that
will you now play
c5 or with e
55 seems a bit slow
so i can have enough time has
prevented his five of
course it looks a bit
shaky
ok
so the question is whether white
can play 25 much earlier
maybe yes  he that
seems uncomfortable at first well I
suspect he's already
done something wrong
that looks very uncomfortable
you do
n't really want to take a
good look from the give you maybe you can
still
provoke the three weaknesses and somehow
play like that  you can take a bishop
moment moment if I pull the bishop away now
he is still fundamentally weak so
six bishops run r6 so that the 68
so that 7 the old man
then maybe I still have
time for thom the eight and then
I would  still to beat in the runner
so
I've overlooked something here
probably have a
look
but otherwise I wouldn't
understand here so if he takes it now yes it
takes I can't either but now you
have to stand somehow okay
or with your legs
yes yes fine  but also help that i have
now de from chancellor like to try everything
so
and now maybe with it b7 with the
idea dirt d5
yes on the five he has a sporty 5 of course
okay but you can reinforce a bit
here
no one understands anymore why not
in addition that's not good for me
so runner the 5
what should come pregnant c3
well what about the pawn is of course
hard with the c pawn
or canada then canale 5 hit
well it's only tight in any case
I have to put a bit of pressure  you
have my god i was slow again
yes now follows runner g5
runner we are in a pretty good position
if it works out well
maybe he'll do a
spinner of the 5 first
and then maybe c6
okay
i have to take it with me somehow
but  the question is
now is the question if i
have a better move the three
maybe they will open three times anyway
i probably have to
win again here by mate anyway because i
was so slow have a
look here
so the cdu yes but
I would still have here the yes there
6 11 6 I only have
that depends first of all 27
yes
of course extremely cheeky to take out
zoom thomas 6
yes I'm getting a bit very cheeky
and for the first time it looks where taken with
the therefore obviously believes a
very long  away